[Applauso]
[Musica]
parto da qui sono nata qui a Carbonara
di Bari in Puglia un quartiere che nel
tempo non ha mai cambiato volto
Frequentavo una scuola che affacciava su
un ospedale abbandonato questo quello
che vedevamo dalle finestre era questo
pachiderma sgraziato proiettato sul filo
sottile delle nostre vite al di là di
quelle vetrate questo ospedale era
abbandonato Allora ed è abbandonato
anche oggi l'effetto che è una simile
bruttura può fare nella vita di un
adolescente duplice da un lato ti
schiaccia la capacità di visione di
prospettiva ti fa venire un forte senso
di sfiducia e allo stesso tempo anche
probabilmente nei casi più gravi di
indifferenza l'altro lato invece
la voglia di allargare la vita allargare
la vista ti porta quel forte senso di
ingiustizia di contrasto
quello che ho ascoltato da quando sono
nata attorno a me un po' come Abbiamo
ascoltato oggi Ognuno di noi ha le
proprie litanie e la mia avveniva in
dialetto carbonarese e italiano non
assite da situato mangio tutto e poi
scrivi bene non densità che hanno le
capid non uscire da sola in mezzo
allegre si dice a Carbonara per dire non
uscire da sola in piazza e poi
arrivavano le domande utilicid quando
poi rispondevi sì o no E quando vi
sposate e poi e i figli oppure quando
frequenti l'università e quando ti
laurei e la chiusa era poi sempre la
stessa non portare lo scompiglio in
questa famiglia disordine
ad ogni mia domanda le risposte
variavano tra qui si è fatto sempre così
oppure qui è stato sempre così a nessuno
veniva in mente di dire Scusate ma se
qui si è fatto sempre così ed è stato
sempre così non mi viene in mente di
cambiare qualcosa se questi sono i
risultati a nessuno nemmeno a me in quel
periodo infatti io onestamente avevo un
pensiero fisso nella testa che il mondo
appartenesse agli altri che il mondo
dovessero farlo gli altri non perché io
avessi un timore a come dire a
confrontarmi con la vita una mancanza di
fiducia oppure una Come dire
un'incapacità a gestire il fallimento la
possibilità di fallire No io non mi
ponevo proprio la domanda
vivevamo un po' come dire ordinatamente
All'Ombra del disordine
concetti come
proiezioni futuro
tensioni agonistica idee per la
collettività non erano assolutamente
vicine al mio mondo come dirvi io ero
sui binari un po' come le signore di
Carbonara che in estate tirano fuori le
sedie di legno oppure di plastica e
stanno nel loro pezzo di strada e
parlano
quel pezzo di strada il loro pezzo di
strada e io ero sul mio e lo tenevo
pulito esattamente come fanno loro con
l'acqua e la candeggina pulito e
ordinato
a sconvolgermi è stata una telefonata
alle 3:00 di notte di febbraio 2007
attraverso quella telefonata entrata
nella mia vita la morte e la paura della
morte e al contempo la vita è la paura
della vita di vivere
la prima reazione che ho avuto per
gestire quel caos interiore che provavo
dentro di me è stata quella di ricercare
l'ordine la pulizia cioè tutto quello
che mi era stato insegnato e dentro di
me Ho sentito una forza dirompente
potente che è diventata praticamente
patologica e questo per me ha
significato diventare ipocondriaca
Praticamente per un paio d'anni ogni
settimana entravo ed uscivo dagli
ospedali Oppure dai medici per sentirmi
dire che almeno dal punto di vista
clinico il mio fisico era in ordine
la strada verso il disordine è stata una
strada molto lunga faticosa costosa
proprio in termini emotivi e fisici ma
assolutamente strabiliante ho scoperto
che l'ordine in quanto sinonimo di
giustizia bellezza verità è una menzogna
è una limitazione culturale e che il
disordine come comunemente si crede
associato al caos al fallimento alla
devianza agli inefficienza alla
sporcizia non è proprio quello
esattamente nella nostra società quello
che noi pensiamo è che solitamente
Diciamo che l'ordine sia sinonimo di
stabilità Ma appunto le colte signore di
Carbonara vi racconterebbero come
dell'acqua Cheta bisogna avere paura
perché quello è un ordine Sono in
apparenza Infatti l'ordine nella nostra
società crea crisi di rigetto e quelli
che oggi vengono chiamati disordini
generazionali il 12,7% dei Minori in
Italia secondo i dati di Save the
Children abbandona precocemente gli
studi e sapete perché Perché molti
ragazzi e molte ragazze non riescono a
stare nel setting precostituito nei
tempi prestabiliti nelle relazioni
preimpostate la stessa cosa nella nostra
società e lo ascoltiamo ogni giorno in
cronaca sta accadendo per gli studenti
universitari sono tantissimi gli
studenti e le studentesse che non
riescono a stare nel corso degli studi
ed è per questo che hanno un sacco di
problemi psicologici Ma per la nostra
società queste persone sono praticamente
Fuori corso Sono esattamente fuori
dall'ordine deciso Sono esattamente
fuori dal tempo standard sono fuori
dalle aspettative Insomma sono fuori dal
si è sempre fatto così ma che cosa
succede se continuiamo ad orientare le
persone i ragazzi in questo modo succede
esattamente come questo come l'ospedale
abbandonato e vi spiego perché ve ne
parlavo anche prima perché c'è stato un
sociologo che si chiama sennet che è 50
anni fa ha scritto un libro che si
chiama usi del disordine e con dopo un
po' ha scritto Mi ha scritto un'altra
dopo diversi anni che si chiama
progettare il disordine sennet spiega
che quando si progettano le città è
importante tenere in considerazione la
variabile dell'imprevisto il disordine
perché città che sono progettate troppo
ordinate Sono città fragili ovvero non
riescono poi a gestire l'imprevisto che
arriva nella vita delle comunità e delle
persone
la stessa cosa accade per le opere
architettoniche esattamente come per
questo ospedale abbandonato questo
ospedale abbandonato è un ospedale che è
destinato a degradarsi è stato sempre
così non è stato mai utilizzato dal Tron
e questo ospedale si è destinata a
degradarsi perché sono subentrati una
serie di imprevisti e non ha più senso
nel contesto in cui è stato costruito un
altro rischio diciamo di non progettare
il disordine per esempio per le opere
architettoniche che le opere
architettoniche possono essere demolite
quindi diventano come dire opere
destinate a non esistere più ad essere
rase al suolo E allora sennet ci spiega
perché è importante Allenare le capacità
trasformative attraverso l'imprevisto
vi voglio raccontare quando ho fatto
l'erasmus Avevo vent'anni sono stata a
Valencia e poi
l'ironia della sorte un po' il mio
destino il mio percorso mi ha portato
fino a qualche mese fa ad essere a capo
dell'agenzia italiana che in Italia
gestisce l'erasmus Youth e nella mia
vita Onestamente ho parlato con
tantissimi ragazze e tantissime ragazze
è quello che io ho sempre colto è sì un
problema di orientamento però allo
stesso tempo anche una forte mancanza di
disorientamento
È incredibile pensare alla mancanza di
disorientamento però se voi pensate
all'erasmus mi dite il motivo per cui
tanti ragazzi e tante ragazze vengono
incoraggiati a fare questa esperienza Sì
per visitare altre università per
acquisire altre competenze tecniche ma
soprattutto per gestire l'imprevisto per
imparare a gestire il disordine e sapete
qual è la cosa che più si trattiene di
questa esperienza i ragazzi quando
tornano dall'erasmus Immagino che
qualcuno di voi sicuramente l'avrà fatto
trattengono di questa esperienza il
tutto il non ho mai fatto così oppure in
tutto il fuori corso tutto quello che
fuori da quello che era previsto dal
loro per esempio piano di studio o da
quello dall'esperienza che si erano
prefissati di fare
E allora come mai sennet ci propone di
come dire progettare il disordine nelle
città e noi non riusciamo a fare questo
quando preimpostiamo i percorsi per le
persone e soprattutto ognuno di noi è
testimone del fatto che nella nostra
vita quando gli eventi che ci
sconvolgono di più sono tutti quelli che
non ci aspettiamo sono tutti quelli che
in inglese definiremmo disordinary fuori
dall'ordinario Invece noi continuiamo a
volere piegare le nostre soggettività le
nostre unicità ad omologarle
nell'ordinario in percorsi
preconfezionati pre impacchettati ed è
per questo che io stasera vi parlo di
progettare di diseducare all'ordine
diseducare all'ordine Sì di educare
all'ordine per me significa
principalmente tre cose La prima
progettare percorsi di disorientamento
significa disinnescare la morsa della
aver instradato tantissimi percorsi di
formazione i ragazzi come cavalli con i
paraocchi Io ovviamente non è che sto
promuovendo l'anarchia nella Rivoluzione
verbale però sto dicendo che è
importante invece nella vita anche
orientare disorientare riuscire a far
conoscere anche il valore del disordine
e questo è importante soprattutto perché
dobbiamo Ognuno di noi deve riuscire a
capire che Talvolta capita che quello
che ci siamo prefissati che delle
aspettative possono essere assolutamente
disattese nella nostra società Tra
l'altro in questo momento secondo me c'è
una forte corsa verso il fallimentismo
come se la cultura del fallire fosse
diventata una moda invece la cultura del
fallire è utilissima soprattutto perché
ci consente di capire che cosa succede
quando si passa attraverso il disordine
e quindi per questo parlo di progettare
percorsi disorientamento il secondo
punto invece riguarda queste giostre
perché la nostra vita Appunto ci
muoviamo disordinatamente esattamente
come queste giostre che ti fanno
particolare C'è un'unica differenza
ognuno di noi nella nostra vita dovrebbe
avere diritto ad avere almeno un punto
di riferimento stabile esattamente
quando ci mettiamo su queste tre giostre
così ti fanno volare però tu sei tenuto
ben sabile al Pilone centrale e quindi
per disorientare c'è bisogno però allo
stesso tempo di avere un punto di
riferimento stabile il terzo punto
invece riguarda la progettazione dei
percorsi di istruzione di studio che
siamo davvero sorprendenti Perché i
percorsi di studio oggi spesso sono
legati ai traguardi su carta abbiamo la
fretta di traguardare su carta abbiamo
bisogno di quel traguardo su carta
Invece noi ci dobbiamo rivolgere appunto
all'istruzione all'educazione per fare
dei percorsi che siano davvero
sorprendenti che ci disorientino che ci
sconvolgano rispetto all'ordinario al
quale Noi siamo abituati o siamo o siamo
stati magari abituati
la scuola l'università il lavoro ci
avvicinano sempre più a contenuti
chiaramente anche di qualità però allo
stesso tempo ci devono poter avvicinare
anche al concetto di felicità che a
pensarci bene però è questo l'abbiamo
letto ovunque felicità e come dire in
inglese si dice Happy che è la stessa
etimologia di alla stessa radice di
Happen Che significa cadere e quindi noi
attraverso questi percorsi dovremmo
semplicemente imparare ad essere felici
accettando il fatto che mentre siamo
sulla strada Tutto può accadere e sapete
dov'è che spesso Tutto accade nelle
famiglie perché le famiglie No sono quel
posto dove spesso ci sono i tentativi di
piegare la soggettività dei componenti
in nome di un ordine condiviso e per me
l'emblema di questo che sto dicendo è la
famosa sedia piena di vestiti nella
stanza di un ragazzo Avete presente
Io ricordo quando mia madre entrava in
camera mia e mi diceva Lucia Metti in
ordine e io rispondevo mamma Ti prego
lascia Questo è il mio ordine e che cosa
ci spiega questo micro mondo della
famiglia questo microepisodio quanti
come dire
quante cose importanti quante cose
sorprendenti quante cose hai dimenticato
di noi troviamo proprio in quella in
quelle sedie piene di vestiti Se ci
pensate E allora propongo che il
disordine diventi un altro degli
strumenti per la crescita diventi uno
strumento per puntare all'eccellenza
perché anche in questo caso abbiamo un
tema eccellere no nel dizionario ci
diranno ci dicono che eccellere
significa essere i primi però
l'eccellenza ovviamente è molto di più
noi quando pensiamo essere i primi
pensiamo siamo portati a pensare a
traguardare per primi dei percorsi
preimpostati e invece no perché
eccellere significa appunto rompere le
celle rompere le limitazioni scavare in
quella sedia piena di vestiti per
ritrovare noi stessi ed è importante
questo perché ogni ragazzo ogni ragazza
davanti alle famose litanie possa
trovare il coraggio e possa vincere la
paura e mettersi ad urlare
Ehi Questo è il mio ordine e allora io
propongo che si diseduchi all'ordina
perché davvero Guardate disse educare
all'ordine è l'unica strada per
diventare straordinari
[Applauso]
[Musica]